unidentified anomalous phenomena are we
talking about aliens yeah
God I hope they're real yeah why are
people scared of aliens I would have one
on the podcast yeah I don't think we'd
talk about
but I mean
if there's aliens out there which I
think there are mathematically I think
it's improbable that we are alone out
here it's uh our ability as a species to
think that we are in so incredibly
unique shocks me sometimes
if they're here visiting I have to
believe that they are
more advanced than we are I would assume
I mean obviously technologically because
they're covering a distance that we are
not capable of covering
um it seems like they are able to evade
detection to a degree and I would
honestly guess that if we are seeing
them it's because they would want us to
see them
but both of those things combined lead
me to believe like if they wanted to
[__] us up they probably already could
have and would have
so
I don't know I think maybe like we're
the comedy planet to them like you win a
prize on some other planet they're like
dude you just won the best prize ever
we're going to send you to this other
planet and you're not gonna believe the
[__] that you're gonna see and so they
come and they watch and they laugh and
they go back and they tell Tales of how
dumb we are but it doesn't work like
like let's get on like this is awesome
sit down and like have a chat with me or
like Bluetooth my mind or wherever that
works I'm not interested in the probing
part you know but like and I don't know
why that was such a narrative early on
yeah kind of like a Freudian thing that
wasn't it I got taken up into the sky
they levitated me up and the first thing
that they did always right at the ass
yeah it's like guys they were they were
forced to be a gape
it's using a verb as a noun you have so
few times in life to use that word that
I think you should seize as much as
possible let's get it in a few more
times before we finish up so David grush
this guy yeah that's the dude yep
I've watched a good bit of stuff on him
and his story
in your professional opinion yep
how reliable do you think that this
particular person's
story security access and clearance all
the rest of it is so a very limited
knowledge of him I actually was exposed
to his videos for the first time
yesterday
um in a very in a very brief article
um so he was in the Air Force I think he
was an intelligence officer he held a TS
SCI clearance
um and apparently he worked for a
program that was peripheral or directly
involved in identifying uaps is what I
think they call call it aliens you know
military officer cool intelligence
officer great TS SCI clearance what's up
it's top secret special
compartmentalized information
and
it sounds like a big deal but honestly
it's not I mean if you look at the uh
not too long ago there was a national
Guardsman the the intelligence League he
was uh he had a TS SCI clearance and
access to these databases because
oftentimes you know to hold certain jobs
you have to have certain clearances it's
the same clearance that I had when I was
uh at the Seal team on the east coast
and it takes about two years to actually
get to clearance so oftentimes you'll
get the job and they'll just give you an
interim clearance meaning you have the
clearance and access to the stuff as if
you edit the background investigation
had been complete but then it takes like
two years to catch up to it it's not an
uncommon clearance it's cool to say and
right out top TS SCI clearance he must
know everything
I was read into with that clearance in
the course of 17 years
I was read into a few programs that
offline I can give you a few Google
search words and you would literally be
able to find the information on the
internet
people's thoughts that
Jason Bourne is like out there
maybe there is in my experience that's
not the case it's a combination and like
this Vice of like 60 people's careers
jammed into one unique little coin and
that's just not the way that it works so
I don't doubt that he might have worked
on a program that was basically around
um identifying unidentified [__] in the
air like that's probably a good idea
like Hey we're kind of seeing these
things that we don't know what they are
let's put together some people to do
that from my understanding that was
nested inside of the Air Force what he
was referencing in the video
and what he seems to be referencing when
he kind of made like the the tour of uh
the media tours well there's this other
program and it's their job to actually
collect things and what I'm hearing is
from these people these senior officers
they are telling me about things that
they saw and for me personally now we're
talking like second and third hand
information it's like listen he's like
oh we weren't read into this program and
we weren't we weren't allowed access to
that one and that's totally common
compartment to the C the the
compartmentalization is totally common
in his status yeah I
was not read into programs that other
people of the commands that I was read
into because there's two things you have
to have you have to have this
appropriate security clearance but then
also the need to know just because you
have a tssci doesn't mean you're like
walking into a skiff which is like a
room about this size where they
keep all this dumb secret [__] or access
to programs you don't just get to go
like oh hey uh yeah I'll be in this gift
for the next three hours and you're just
thumbing through stuff that's like a
library yeah it's not the way that it
works so if this guy's job which I don't
doubt that he held that job
and I don't even necessarily doubt that
other people would be coming up to him
and saying to him hey this is what I saw
and this is what I did but it's not
uncommon that they are going to separate
programs that might have something to do
with each other
but the best way to keep a secret is to
keep it compartmentalized and separate
like I'm sure that even when it went
back to uh you know creating the first
the Manhattan Project I bet you there
were people who are working on that
project that years later were like oh
[__] I actually designed me well I
designed my housing that was my [__]
I designed that wire they had no idea
why because it was compartmentalized why
because we were trying to keep it a
secret so
I personally don't think that we're
alone I hope that we're not alone like I
would legitimately like what's up dude
let's go have a beer alien do you drink
beer like what's going on here I don't
think there's as much to be scared of as
people may think but these people coming
forward like I have all the secret
information
and then I'm not gonna actually give you
a shred of it
to me puts their legitimacy in question
anybody that doesn't have first-hand
knowledge of something but there's some
other interesting stuff that in order to
be able to communicate this information
he had to get I think it's Department of
Defense or
Security Homeland Security clearance to
be able to say these things and he was
allowed it's not much of a whistleblower
then no so he was allowed to say these
things yes they said so they have
determined that what he was going to say
is not classified information yeah
because he had to get the clearance in
order to be able to get this out at
least this is what was reported on Fox
News so then what the hell is actually
going on Joe's theory is that they're
trying to steal more money from us
who
the government they're trying to
distract us with aliens while they pass
some other [__] that takes more money
from us
he thinks it's a false look over there
the aliens are over there the debt
ceiling nobody needs to see this he his
he's Landing more on I think this is
actually an intelligence operation
trying to point our uh attention false
flag yeah actually in another Direction
but psychological false flag
yeah well here's the thing who's that um
that president that said uh if only we
were attacked by an alien force we would
how quickly would Humanity's differences
be forgotten so it was maybe Reagan or
somebody like that anyway uh the point
being that at the moment because largely
life is very comfortable and there is no
existential threat apart from the ones
that people make up and population
collapse uh apart from the ones that
people are concerned about that are in
the news
the only enemies that people have are
the ones inside right the ones internal
to their Nation I actually think that if
you were to say there is a an alien
civilization that's out there we're not
sure if it's hostile or if it's uh
benign
you would actually end up with quite a
bit of cohesion because For the First
Time Ever humans tribal biases are able
to be deployed against something other
than humans well it's a threat for the
entire population just not one segment
of the population correct people are
brought together much more of a shared
hatreds than shared loves at the moment
there is more hatred than there is love
but if the hatred could be directed at
something in the sky or somebody out
there you could white pill this and say
oh you know there's actually a potential
good that comes out of this but yeah I I
don't know man it's there's a lot of
different people that are part of this
story like this lady that's involved
that was helped to feed David this
information is this lady that's been a
part of sort of a UFO truth or
conspiracy theory for many years well
it's so let's say that
let's play this out as if everything
he's saying is true so he was not part
of the program
specifically but he's hearing that there
is a program that exists somewhere
nested inside of the dod
that they go out and they retrieve all
of these things for one that would be
an enormous operation where first off
you'd have to staff it and man it so
we're talking you'd have to have
aircraft specifically dedicated for that
so you'd have people up front flying the
aircraft you'd have people in the back
of the aircraft and the people in the
back of the aircraft are going to be
probably Junior personnel and my point
in all this is like the more people that
see this the more people that like try
to keep a secret among five people and
then add a zero to that and then add a
zero to that how is this director of
leakage that's what I'm saying like
you're trying to tell me that somewhere
there it's nested inside of the dod and
they have a dedicated Wing that's doing
this and they're flying all over the
place and nobody
can give me one concrete shred of
evidence
well that's
you said earlier on about people need to
be able to sort of hold two thoughts in
their mind at once this is a relatively
difficult one for some people some of
the time to do which is
the government and the New World Order
is unbelievably sophisticated and able
to coordinate itself so that Global
Health passports and microchips in our
vaccines and aliens are able to be kept
from us
and also the government is so useless
that I wouldn't trust them with anything
and they are completely incompetent in
all of the rest of it it's like Yo which
one is it yeah which one is it is it
that they're able to coordinate a half
thousand person operation to be able to
go and retrieve the most valuable
artifact of non-human origin ever
discovered even including meteors in in
plain sight we haven't figured it out
yet
and not a single not a single verifiable
leak yeah or is it that they're
completely useless and nobody should
ever be trusted and the government needs
to get the [__] out of my life I'm
totally fine with both of those things
being true that there can be portions of
it that do both
in my opinion what is it hanlon's razor
did not attribute to malice that which
can be explained by stupidity it's like
do not attribute to conspiracy that
which can be explained by people that
just really really are good at lying
agreed and you know there could be a
third option somewhere in between those
two where you kind of said it there's a
small because the government and these
organizations are just people would it
be possible to find people that are
super capable and competent and operate
well inside of an incompetent government
yes well that's the C again right that's
what I'm saying yes you could
but man
my personal [__] meter goes off
pretty pretty rapidly and also and I
don't know why there was something about
the way that the individual was talking
about it that just was like the good
Instinct yeah it's like I don't know man
maybe he's telling that maybe he's
talking about things he truly believes
uh but there was there was something
about it that rung off to me that's
always something that I find interesting
you know when there's a a missing child
and the parents go out and they do the
Press tour there's this a girl called
Madeleine McCann in the UK very famous
child that went missing I think in
Turkey in sort of the mid 90s and the
number of conspiracies about her parents
that they'd kidnapped her they'd sold
her into slavery or they'd been
negligent to her or some of the [__]
which very well may be true
um and people were analyzing how they'd
done their press conferences and one of
the interesting things I reflected on
there is they were saying these people
are unreliable actors look at nobody
nobody would act this way when giving a
press conference about their lost
daughter I'm like oh sorry hang on
where's the [__] Handbook of examples
of how people are supposed to normally
behave yeah
studies missing like because there's two
they've either killed a chapter up and
and spread her in the sea or she's been
stolen right like I can give you pay
more options than that
let's be creative how are you today
you're the guy you're the guy that would
dispose of the body so but my point
being like how how are you supposed to
behave like how do you behave and the
same thing goes for this guy so you know
in terms of some degrees of freedom
let's say that you do have these you
know again do not attribute to malice
that which can be explained by stupidity
or perhaps um incompetence yeah or
culpability or or believability from
this guy you know he he could be telling
the truth so you've been given this
information by these people that have
said that this is true they seem
reputable to you perhaps they also
believe that it's reputable perhaps it's
second or third hand from them you don't
know where it goes
what's the playbook for how you're
typically supposed to be able to give an
interview to the Press claiming that
this is potentially the first alien
craft but the other thing what was it he
said he said something about there's
been a non-human remember that you know
he almost read it like a novel it was
like there's been uh he said basically a
pilot exactly and uh you know that's the
same in this one I'm like is this a
[__] Thriller novel or something well
also don't forget you know both you and
I I'm used to being around cameras like
they don't bother me anymore I could
only imagine let's say let's again go
down the
thought process of he everything he has
is the truth and he is actually trying
to be a whistleblower and this is the
first time he's ever had a camera in
front of his face you're gonna ask a
little you're gonna act a little awkward
yeah yeah
yet NASA's got this panel for uaps
apparently and they are encouraging
commercial pilots to come forward did
you talk about this do you know so this
is pretty interesting so NASA's got this
panel right there's these uaps that are
happening again this may be uh
uh part of the conspiracy to the false
flag thing but what they're doing is it
seems like commercial pilots because
they spend way more time in the skies
than all militaries combined by a
[__] huge margin
they observe a variety of strange aerial
phenomena but there is a stigma in the
commercial Aviation Community around
Pilots submitting this yeah because
they're going to think you're crazy in
February alone the FAA had 68 reports
One commercial pilots so this is NASA
trying to encourage a cultural shift
amongst commercial pilots for them to
come forward so that they're going to be
less reluctant to report it because
again you're going to be shunned and
maybe milked as a crazy person uh and
yeah in February alone the FAA had 68
reports of uh uaps by commercial pilots
I think we should embrace it I I mean
if we're not alone and they want to come
here I don't think we're going to stop
them so let's embrace the fact that it's
possible and you know the commercial
pilots yeah I think for years the stigma
has been oh you believe in aliens
tractor beam huh probe yeah I get it
yeah totally so
I think I actually think it's a really
good thing
um I actually have quite a bit of flying
experience and sometimes you see weird
[__] up there report it and what you're
gonna get is probably the vast majority
of those things are things that were
reported that can be explained but you
might get a small minority of them where
you can look into it and we can develop
a better understanding of whether or not
we are alone or not just just tell the
goddamn truth if you see something
you'll understand
that's unrecognizable make a report on
it and
yeah I I just
I'd rather lean into it
make some popcorn invite them down like
why not what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace